and what is it about writing that you
find so powerful and why do you think
you're actually so good at it because
you know I'm a writer obviously and I
read your stuff and there's very few
people I read and I would you know like
and you probably have this experience I
suppose - as a writer sometimes you read
somebody and you're like thought that
person's good yeah I wish I want that
sentence I wish I wrote that essay yeah
what is it that draws you to writing and
why do you think you've connected with
people in that medium sure I think that
I don't actually view myself as a very
good writer first of all they're well
well I read people like John McPhee or
I'll read Neil Stevenson and I just want
to cry more beautiful complex gist are
the pros and the the multiple threads
that they can they can tie together in
this beautiful package at the end and
you're just astonished that they're able
to pull these things together Cloud
Atlas another example however there's a
there's a difference between beautiful
prose and effective writing and their
different types of effective writing
what I think I try very hard to do is be
a good teacher using words as my medium
and I think I'm very good at being an
impatient reader and that translates at
least for me to being able to identify
exactly for instance at what point in a
business book is the reader gonna be
like are you [ __ ] kidding me like you
told me that like to live with integrity
and hire the right people how do I hire
the right people and then they're like
Oh [ __ ] detect right it's like well
you have to ask you know the questions
like blah blah blah it's like well give
me four more examples and I'm very
impatient for details in that way so I
can look at my own writing with the same
lens the second thing I would say is I
feel I cheat a bit with my writing in
the sense that it's very hard for me to
pontificate and come out with something
very interesting and there are there are
many people who can write much more
beautiful prose who will kill me in that
department but there are very few people
who are willing to do the absurd
extreme experiments that I'm willing to
do myself so if you want to have
interesting writing the cheat is just do
really crazy slash interesting stuff and
guess what like if your grammar sucks
and your and your your prose is a little
broken as long as you have a clear voice
and you have a strong position and you
have an interesting story people will
read that and it will travel